24 degrés c'était la météo avec sirius
fabricant de chauffe eau solaires à la
réunion aujourd'hui lundi c'est le lundi
politique bonjour galles de l'umq m
bonjour j'essaie bonjour à tous l lundi
politique
gaël le dantec dans moins d'un mois plus
de 630 mille réunionnais sont invités à
choisir leurs représentants au parlement
européen parlement amenés à voter sur
les terrains qui les lois et règlements
qui s'appliqueront dans cette loi est
donc ici aussi à la réunion
pourtant la participation cette année
risque d'être encore limitée en 2014
était d'à peine 20 % ici les sondages de
la liste connaissance de la majorité
présidentielle au coude à coude avec
celle du rassemblement national mais il
reste plusieurs semaines de campagne
dans un contexte de crise sociale et
deux propositions post grand débat pour
ce qui concerne la france le
rassemblement national nouveau nom du
front national peut-il convaincre les
électeurs réunionnais de se déplacer
pour quelle politique européenne
marie-luce brasil 1 60e sur la liste du
rassemblement national est l'invitée
d'un des politiques sur la première
jusqu'à 13h vos questions à partir de
12h45 au 0262 99 2000
marie-luce parisé clan bonjour je
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous êtes 60e je lisais sur la liste de
duras national pour ces élections
européennes pourquoi pourquoi si loin il
n'y avait pas de réunionnais qui
méritait pas du tout les places elles
sont limitées et et le il y avait les
députés sortants à repositionner après
des candidats stratégique et ensuite
quand on regarde les places éligibles
sont pas en si grand nombre et vous avez
eu 24 députés élus lors des dernières
élections où on aurait pu imaginer un
candidat oui on aurait pu mais la
réunion connaît marine le pen la réunion
connaît le programme de marine le pen la
réunion nous suit la réunion fera
un score nous accordera un score
important est par contre et c'est est
préférable de mettre quelqu'un comme une
guadeloupéenne en position éligible pour
que le rassemblement national marine le
pen son projet il soit bien entendu dans
dans les antilles
c'était plus important qu'il soit
entendu aux antilles tout cela est bien
avec la député guadeloupéen enfin la
future députée européenne guadeloupéen
la réunion sera entendue également s
occupera de tout l'outre-mer donc et
c'est là une président et les voleurs de
la crise bien plus d'électeurs ici
potentiel un bon score ici pour les
élections présidentielles on a du mal à
comprendre aussi des candidats y en
avait les candidats ne manquent ne
manquent pas à part vous y avez qui
voulait intégrer cette liste il y en
avait et pas mal en métropole commission
je prends en exemple devait être cinq
d'accord les autres ont plutôt entre 5
et 7 mais ils n'ont pas été retenus
faute de place à c'est pas faute
vous regrettez de ne pas être au mieux
pas du tout j'irai peut-être parlement
européen 160e non oui mais peut-être que
je pars je participerai juste ray
collaboratrice d'un député européen en
tant qu'élu en tout cas vous n'irez pas
en tant qu'élu je n'irai pas cette fois
la prochaine je suis toujours dans le
dans le train je suis dans un wagon et
la prochaine fois
vraisemblablement dans le wagon de tête
marine le pen vient faire campagne ici
pour récolter des voix on l'a vu un pour
l'exploitation pour ce qu'il ya un mois
environ
et pourtant
ne semble pas réussir à implanter le
mouvement si localement
si le mouvement il est un beau score
pour les scrutins locaux sont très bas
ça n'a rien à voir entre le un score
local et un ska un score national ça n'a
rien à voir
en quand eux quand il s'agit d'une
élection locale nous sommes des petits
poids face à des grosses pointures en
france six mois si si j'ai si j'habitais
la métropole j'aurais sûrement été élu
aujourd'hui 1 c'est plus facile d'être
élu en métropole qu'à la réunion donc
réunionnais sont très sensibles aux
idées
les réunionnais sont sensibles à nos
idées nous ne sommes pas aidés ni par la
presse et nous nous trouvons souvent
face à de grosses machines politiques
avec beaucoup de gros budget donc nous
faisons pas le poids mais nous allons
bientôt faire le poids je pense que les
élections européennes vont ouvrir la
voie à l'implantation de du
rassemblement national du projet de
marine le pen dans à la réunion dans
tous les outre-mer mariage princier clan
dans l'actualité de ce matin cette
expulsion de 60 migrants vers du sri
lanka
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous dites
c'est bien l'état fait son travail et
vous dommage qu'il n'ait pas attendu que
tous les recours en justice étaient
examinés pour que ça se fasse son son
question auditore tous les sujets y
compris ceux les 34 euros et le droit de
demander asile
moi je vais vous dire je pense
sincèrement que il
ils repartiront étant donné que il l'a
les autorités ont dû prendre cette
décision
1 par rapport aux élections européennes
qui dans
qui sont croches et sur l'immigration
fait partie du programme de marine le
pen si les sri lankais reste à la
réunion forcément les gens mais je pense
que la plupart des réunionnais ne sont
sont en accord avec en désaccord avec
cette immigrée désaccord avec cette
immigration et si j'étais resté sur le
sol réunionnais les
je pense que les autorités pensent que
les renier les réunionnais vont
davantage se tourner vers le programme
de marine le pen aux français que l'état
a fait expulser ces essais encaissés
deux voleurs asile pour vous couper
l'herbe sous le pied pour que tout est
possible puisque l'aller les réunionnais
qui sont contre l'immigration sont
satisfaits et ils pensent que l'état va
dans le bon sens alors que ce n'est pas
du tout le cas à l'immigration fait
partie du programme de l'union
européenne
ils sont pour l'immigration massive pour
un poulain imposer un quota dans chaque
pays membre
alors on va revenir sur la politique
européenne en matière d'immigration
mais pour rester sur la question
rennaise comment est-ce qu'il faut
s'organiser face à l'arrivée
finalement qui devient presque régulière
de bateaux avec à chaque fois quelques
dizaines de demandeurs d'asile pour
l'instant du sri lanka ce qu'il faut
qu'on organise leur accueil pour que ça
se passe dans de meilleures conditions
que ce que vous préconisez
écoutez il faut déjà une politique de
l'immigration dissuasive et avec
l'instant il faut instaurer des
frontières des contrôles la réunion
occupe un point stratégique géographique
et il faudrait un contrôle des
frontières également dans la zone océan
indien et afin de protéger non seulement
la réunion mayotte au reste du corps
protégé de l'immigration c'est à dire 10
dissuader les migrants de prendre la mer
et de venir s'installer à la réunion
halal à l'heure actuelle la réunion ne
peut pas se permettre d'accueillir une
sens ou centaines de migrants par
semaine c'est impossible
pourquoi nous n'avons pas les moyens
l'immigration coûte ça a un coût et cet
argent ils pourraient ils pourraient
profiter aux réunionnais il pourrait
profiter par exemple est ce que vous
trouvez normal que qui est un montant
colossal qui est qu'il soit attribué
pour l'accueil de ces migrants est
colossal
je n'ai pas les chiffres mais en tout
cas des migrations coûte elle peut aussi
rapporter et des études qui montrent que
les immigrés quand ils sont intégrés
travail paie des impôts et participe à
la l'activité économique le chômage
ce sera mieux que les français qui
travaillent la demande etc accueilli
près d'1 million de réfugiés vers
2015-2016 a vu sa croissance économique
de transporter sais pas ce que disent
les allemands et donc pour en revenir
jusque 10 le chiffre à l'immigration moi
je préférerais nous préférions par
exemple lorsque les réunionnais doivent
se rendre en métropole pour des soins
ils sont obligés de quémander de 2,2 à
d'avoir affaire à de se rapprocher de la
cagnotte clichy il ya des problèmes de
l'os mais cet argent pourrait servir
l'argent dépensé à la réunion pour les
immigrés ça représente quoi gêner pour
cent de la population
vous savez quand on est quand on parle
par exemple d'une retraite chez sur une
perte de temps sur une petite pension
lorsqu'on enlève 20 ou 30 euros c'est
énorme pour la personne pourquoi
l'immigration particulièrement aux
dépenses de l'état sur le sujet que vous
pourriez fustigé pourquoi est-ce que
c'est l'immigration et et autre chose
mais il ne faut pas faire l'amour
jusqu'à
oui bien sûr savait pas pourquoi plus
les migrations pourquoi une fixation sur
ampli l'immigration n'est pas un
problème
l'immigration c'est vous qui dites vous
dites que l'immigration n'est pas un
problème est déjà un problème puisqu'il
faut qu'il paraît il ya le il faut les
loger les nourrir
y aller les avocats qui sont nommés il
faut les reconduites à la frontière vous
pensez que tout ça ça coûte dessous non
c'est un coup quand même pour un pour
ceux qui sont dans la misère
cet argent pourrait leur profiter même
si c'est pas grand chose même si ça
correspond à une une baguette ou 10
baguettes saprophytes ça profiterait aux
réunionnais on a pu lire sur les réseaux
sociaux beaucoup de commentaires
particuliers ne il raciste
l'agent de l'arrivée de ces migrants ce
que ça vous inquiète 7 707 paroles
haineuses qui se libère oui je n'aime
pas ces paroles haineuses d'ailleurs
vous ne verrez vous ne m'entendrez
jamais prononcé des paroles haineuses
je dis tout simplement que nous sommes
contre l'immigration que les sri lankais
devrait rester chez eux même s'ils sont
menacés chez eux mais ils ne sont pas
forcément menacé il ya une minorité de
menaces et donc il faut les écouter voir
absolument si on veut qu'ils sont
arrivés
récemment il y en a 34 qui est autorisé
à demander ce qu'ils obtiendront des
autres vise à demander l'asile ça veut
dire que les autorités considèrent qu'
ils sont suffisamment danger chez eux
pour qu'on examine leur cas ouais alors
il pourrait partir dans un pays plus
riches
peut-être qu'ils veulent juste aller en
europe en passant par chez nous c'est ce
qu'on pense tout à fait mais bon
franchement je ne sais pas vous savez
non non ils ont quoi voilà peut-être
peut-être que ce qu'ils veulent c'est
aller en europe ce qu'ils veulent ce
qu'ils ont dit d'ailleurs pas sûr c'est
qu'il était censé partir mais c'est plus
facile de dire qu'ils étaient censés
partir en nouvelle zélande plutôt qu'ici
c'est une porte qui se dérobe marque je
croisais cancale et cette europe que
vous propose aux électeurs réunionnais
ont un peu perdu vous voulez rester de
l'ordre dans l'europe voulant sortir
alors nous souhaitons une alliance
européenne des nations
c'est à dire que tous les pays seraient
considérés sur le même plan c'est à dire
que le avec marines et une europe des
protections des libertés et des peuples
contrairement à cette europe qui nous
est imposée depuis des décennies et qui
correspond à un mondialisme libéral
dicté par l'union européenne
est ce que le royaume uni a bien fait de
quitter l'eau de l'union européenne oui
à leur leçon devrait pas pareil oui vous
êtes plutôt pour un freak sitôt oui mais
je vais vous dire le flexible n'arrive
pas c'est pas nul mais c'est vous qui
dites que je suis pour le forcing sur le
fric si tu n'y arriveras pas étant donné
que nous à nouveau le regrettez vous
souhaiteriez vous que la france qui dope
non nous allons former une alliance
européenne des nations on parle toujours
d'europe mais je brûle sel
ne va pas nous dicter notre ce qu'on
doit faire parce que là on est à la soul
sous le commandement de bruxelles et el
bruxelles e selectric des technocrates
qui décident à notre place vient de
direction oui oui les gens qui décident
qu'ils ne séjournent voter oui mais ils
ont été élus en europe pour l'europe
mais l'a par exemple quand on prend le
programme de monsieur du président
macron on voit très bien que ce sont des
directives
ce sont des points qui sont imposées par
l'union européenne
que ça soit en matière des 35 heures que
ça soit le report de l'âge légal de la
retraite
l'immigration etc tout ceci est dictée
par l'union repas et sert que la france
n'a pas le droit de décider ce qu'elle
souhaite pour son pays
autrement elle avoue est candidat pour
intégrer le parlement européen qui va
prendre ce genre de décision oui mais le
parlement européen va subir des
transformations dans son mode de
fonctionnement puisque
vraisemblablement nous serons
majoritaires
donc le mode de fonctionnement va être
revu justement avec qui est ce que vous
pensez pouvoir vous alliez au niveau
européen puisque vous n'êtes pas
forcément tous d'accord les partis on va
dire dix nationalistes souverainistes
vous n'êtes pas et pas tout à fait la
même
la même vision politique sont par
exemple matteo salvini en italie
demandent à ce que tous les pays
européens partagent le coût de migration
et partage ses immigrés sur les côtes
notamment l'italienne ou gracq et puis
je t'ordonne qui est aussi celui dont on
parle il pas qu'il y aura là dessus
c'est qu'ils vous alliez les alliés il
on va faire une alliance les alliés
chacun d'eux prendra sa décision le
matteo salvini
on prendra il est contre l'immigration
on le suivra celui qui sera pour il
assumera on trouvera un terrain
d'entente c'est prévu de toute façon
pour fonctionner pour que l'alliance
européenne et des nations fonctionne il
faut une entente et la communication
entre les différents membres plus de 2
milliards d'euros
vous souhaitez que l'europe conserve
cette aide à lannion oui nous souhaitons
que les l'aide apportée par l'europe à
la réunion soit maintenu et d'ailleurs
je dois dire que à propos de la pac et
c'est prévu une diminution de la une
baisse de
là des fonds pour la pac et des fonds
structurels et six hommes politiques oui
la politique agricole commune et nous
sommes pour le maintien enfin le
maintien du niveau et comment est ce
qu'on fait pour maintenir une aide
solidaire de tous les pays européens et
de toutes les régions européennes si on
est pour l'europe moi des gens elle est
plus de deux replis
est-ce que vous conservez le bûcher est
ce que vous êtes pour un futur
c'est une question il ya des
spécialistes qui se sont penchés sur le
projet sur ce projet donc ça a été
étudiée voilà spécialistes ce sera vous
si le député je ne serai pas débuté mais
je serai candidate contre tout à fait
mais je veux dire si ça a été écrit
marine elle n'a pas droit à l'erreur
marine le pen n'a pas droit à l'erreur
il ya un projet d'accord il est écrit et
donc on doit suivre le projet il faut
qu'elle fasse tout ce qu'il faut
poursuivre le projet puisque si elle ne
le projet n'est pas suivi si le projet
ne tient pas la route
forcément ça va s'écrouler donc il ya
aucune raison le projet il n'a pas été
élaborée à la légère c'est un projet qui
tient la route est un projet solide et
d'ailleurs il nous l'expliqué sur
solidarité sur ce budget qu'on a ce
qu'on fait pour assurer le même niveau
de transferts budgétaires des depuis
l'europe de la réunion si on réduit
finalement la participation de chacun
d'eux et à écouter
là j'ai vu que dans le projet c'est
écrit alors on est contre la baisse de
la pac et la diminution la fabrication
ne passera 15 jours alors il ya des
photos de l'es2
en arrivant un père it impérativement
doivent être maintenus le taux de
financement préférentiel pour les fonds
européens feder et fse
les mesures spécifiques en matière de
politique agricole posséder le taux des
deux majoré pour les aides à la pêche
el fahem prix pour parler russe on
jamais globalement sur la somme allouée
ils avaient tous passé mais si le budget
est globalement en net diminue sur sa
finition d'état ça ne fera pas une
diminution la france s'occupera
davantage de des ultramarins en étant en
ayant ses députés élus à l'assemblée
européenne des nations je ne parlerai
pas de l'union européenne mais
l'assemblée européenne des nations
les députés européens du rassemblement
national n'ont pas voté le programme
laly programme feder speed 1 milliard
d'euros ce sont des aides aux
entreprises au niveau bac en a besoin
vous ne souhaitez pas que le feder tel
qu'il a été proposé soit appliquée à
chaque fois c'est comme vous savez le
flat vous me parlez des déchets verts
qui n'avaient pas été votés par le
rassemblement national
il ya eu également
madame l'oiseau qui parlait de la des
travailleurs tête de liste de liste de
présence et des travailleurs détachés
mais en fait on nous on nous demande de
voter quelque chose qui va à l'encontre
de notre projet donc ça veut pas dire
qu'on est contre c'est vous de ces
subventions
il ya quelque chose qui bloque dans
cette voie là je ne suis pas spécialiste
sur le plan de la ferme mais marine le
pen
il y avait une journaliste qui lui avait
dit ici je ne sais plus laquelle qui
avait dit ici que la volt est contre et
et du coup elle avait donné un
justificatif et un prouvant que c'était
pas possible d'aller dans le sens qu'on
leur demandait au niveau 2 de ce traité
mais vous ne savez pas mais je me
renseignerai je vous la porterai vous si
vous êtes majoritaires si vous arrivez à
faire ce que vous appelez cette europe
des nations s qui aura encore une
politique aucun commune où est ce que
l'idée c'est que chaque pays finalement
fasse un peu ce qu'il souhaite et puis
passe juste des accords économiques
notre centre sur certains sujets c'est
quand le fonctionnement de toute cette
mobilisation c'est justement d'avoir de
partir sur une politique économie
européenne commune une alliance
l'alliance
le terme et parlant en lui-même une
alliance européenne des nations c'est à
dire que les
et les nations seront unis vont se
préoccuper de sur le plan économique
social de tous les tous les pays
européens et décider de des projets
communs pour avancer pour que le toutou
les que les pays tous les pays avance
sur le plan économique social les
régions ultra périphériques comme la
réunion dans les rues pour 50 degrés
d'autonomie vis-à-vis règles européennes
est ce qu'il faut
selon groulx plus d'autonomie ou au
contraire rester plus dans le giro
français nationale s'il faut s'éloigner
un petit peu de 2 des voix qui
s'impliquent dans les autres régions
départements en termes de fiscalité doit
relations commerciales avec nos voisins
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on aille vers plus
d'autonomie dans le cadre de ces rues où
est-ce qu'au contraire il faut rester
dans le giro est foncée et robert il
faut rester dans le giron et français et
européens il nous faut surtout pas
s'éloigner au contraire là les rues qu
on des atouts et ses atouts ils sont
inexploités 1
par exemple pour parler de mon pare d'or
bleu l'outre-mer fait partie intégrante
de la france et parmi ses nombreux
atouts elle a plus de 11 millions de
kilomètres carrés d'océan et qui fait
que la france est le premier domaine
maritime mondial et ce qu'il nous faut
préconiser c'est la création d'une
agence européenne de la mer dont le
siège se tiendrait en outre-mer savez il
ya aussi le l'argent ok je suis moi nous
a fait mal sur l'autonomie
et justement pas d'autonomie il faut
qu'on soit quand qu'on soit considéré
comme un département comme un autre
comme un autre et qu'on soit lié à la
france est considérée par par l'europe
par l'alliance européenne et considéré
par leur l'alliance européenne l'union
européenne manque de considération
vis-à-vis des rup
il faut pas ici d'adaptation au
règlement européen qui sont peut-être
parfois vécue comme un peu vous disiez
tout à l'heure
bureaucratique et lointain il faudrait
des dérogations pour sortir elle
conquiert le jeune tout à fait sains il
ya un traité le traité de fonctionnement
de l'union européenne qui permet à
l'outre-mer de bénéficier des mesures
d'adaptation par rapport aux règles
européennes
est ce qu'on souhaite c'est une
application maximale du régime
d'adaptation donc en fait vous voulez
plus d'autonomie ou pas plus d'autonomie
on va dire non une collaboration une
collaboration pour rester sur ce même
sujet mais peut-être un autre vouloir
plus de décentralisation est ce que
comme vis-à-vis de l'europe vous dites
c'est bien qu'il y ait plus d'autonomie
à la réunion par rapport à trois
endroits français qui s'applique en
force éternel ou est-ce que vous vous
c'est bien est ce que vous vous créez on
s'éloigne un peu de la reine nationale
je pense qu'on va s'éloigner un des
règles nationales s'y prendre une
certaine distance comme le préconise
monsieur macron dont vous n'êtes pas
pour cette différenciation proposé par
est ce que vraiment trop d'idées vous
seriez vous pour plus de préférence
locale al embauche
oui tout à fait c'est c'est une
différence c'est une dérogation par
rapport au droit français
oui les dérogations une cette dérogation
est là elle a son importance tout à fait
est-ce qui fait ce qu'il faut aussi que
à la réunion on puisse éloignerait le
national sur la laïcité est ce que on
peut avoir ici d exception parce que
l'histoire de la réunion parce que le
multiculturalisme ici fait qu'on peut
s'éloigner peut-être des règles
nationales
tout à fait oui absolument pour toutes
les religions
oui oui comme un ces deux là le
multiculturalisme culturalisme fait
partie de notre de notre pays de notre
de nos futurs coutume donc on ne sait
pas vraiment la ligne du rassemblement
national à la mise en avant du
multiculturalisme que ce soit la
spécialité de marine le pen lorsqu'elle
était venue à la réunion elle était
partie dans un dans un culte tamouls
donc voilà mais par ailleurs se
prononcer contre les prix y alain contre
les prières de rue sésame il n'y a pas
de prières de rue à la réunion où par
contre les prières de rue sont
envahissantes à la réunion ça se passe
très bien justement ya passé prières de
rue
contrairement à la métropole la réunion
a été très touché par par le mouvement
des jeunes
je n'ai pas participé mais je soutiens
le mouvement des gilet jaune
je comprends leurs revendications et je
profite pour dire que les politiques
locaux ont essayé de se joindre au gilet
jaune et ils n'ont pas réussi ils ont
été repoussés par les gilet jaune à
juste titre est aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'ils font ils vont ils ont été se
rapproche enfin ils sont partis se
rapprocher de du parti de la république
en marge du parti du président macron
tête avec suivre là ils sont partis
suivre la tête de liste madame l'oiseau
tête de liste de pour les européennes
sur le kivu par les jeux monsieur x ça
par exemple un monsieur didier robert un
qui j'ai fait d'autres
un président de région
peut-être c'est mes souvenirs sont bons
jeux en tout cas il y en a eu plusieurs
que vous soulevez dans ce mouvement
gilet jaune toujours aujourd'hui y
compris dans les dents des
rassemblements qui continua à se faire
tous les samedis à paris pas du tout je
pense qu'il devrait revoir leur copie et
voir un autre mode pour se faire
entendre
il est devenu insupportable intolérable
le tissu économique
un de métropole est en train de
s'effondrer dans certaines grandes
villes il ya la violence il ya des
blessés des mutilés donc c'est
inadmissible il faut que les gilets
jaunes revoient leurs leur stratégie et
vous préconiseriez quoi vous qu'il ait
soutenu se regroupent et puis voir
quelque chose qui soit beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus marquant beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus souple au goût plus temps
mais pas de pas de violence vous
condamner les violences policières
je ferai tout à fait je condamne les
violences qu'elles la violence quelle
qu'elle soit c'est la première fois
peut-être que le rassemblement national
et pas du côté des forces de l'ordre pas
du côté des policiers
mais le rassemblement national est du
côté des policiers a toujours été du
côté des policiers
mais quand quand il ya agression
ça change je veux pas être du côté de
celui qui agresse autant dans les gilet
jaune que dans les forces de l'autre
pour répondre à ce mouvement des jeunes
ici localement la région propose de
financer une partie du fret une partie
donc de ce que le président de la région
la continuité territoriale des biens et
des marchandises
est ce vrai que l'europe finance cette
cette aide est ce que vous
vous allez demander je vous dites vous
même que vous n'irez pas siéger au
parlement à strasbourg mais ce que vous
demandez vos colistiers éventuellement
une fois élus de soutenir cette idée
tout à fait un marine dans son programme
elle a toujours voulu instaurer un
couloir économique prioritaire entre la
métropole et la réunion et la métropole
et et les autres départements donc mais
bien sûr pour pouvoir favoriser les
échanges avoir moins de moins de taxes
bien sûr même si ça peut compromettre
éventuellement le développement
d'activités de production locale ça ne
compromettra pas forcément l'activité de
production locale je pense que
d'ailleurs et on a aussi la prévu de
revoir le mode de fonctionnement du de
l'octroi de mer pour que les produits
locaux soient valorisés la produit le
localisme marie marine le pen parle de
localisme
juste une dernière on va aller au sens
large qu'on a des appels avec juste une
sur ce point là vous vous dites qu'il
faut un corridor un couloir pour entre
la métropole et la réunion ça veut dire
que c'est préférable de commercer avec
paris plutôt qu'avec les pays alentour
non il est possible de commercer autant
avec paris qu'avec les pays alentour
mais tout dépend de ce qu'ils proposent
nous avons avec nous téléphonent salué
le moine qui nous appellent bonjour
semaine - on écoute votre question vos
intérêts je suis de cette campagne des
élections européennes
ma première question a porté sur la
stratégie d'éducation et de formation
que proposeront mouvements politiques et
notamment bretons liste aux élections
européennes
je suppose que vous connaissez les
champs de compétence de la commission
européenne et que les sujets que
j'évoque éducation formation aux
intérêts
deuxième chose compte tenu de la
défiance on regarde la classe politique
en quoi votre formation politique peut
être un encouragement pour les
réunionnais d'aller voter le 26 mai une
bonne campagne
merci sam éloigne pour vos deux
questions marie-luce brazy klein notre
invité vous à bron oui un port en venir
à l'éducation et à la formation c'est la
base même du développement d'un pays
donc ça fait partie intégrante du des du
programme de marine le pen les
les enfants d'elle
dès la petite enfance eux doivent être
pris en charge et bien formés que
l'europe ne peut l'europe apporté donner
des fonds pour pouvoir ouvrir davantage
d'écoles prévoir davantage de formation
ce que c'est à l'europe de décider
combien d'écoles on doit ouvrir ça peut
être discuté c'est pas à l'europe de
décider justement c'est en fonction du
besoin de chaque pays et en terme de
formation c'est pareil par rapport par
rapport au chômage ya des secteurs qui
sont qui offre des débouchés et d'autres
non on se rend compte que il ya l'offre
et la demande
et souvent il est dit que
il ya des propositions d'emploi qui ne
trouvent jamais d'acquéreurs et ce qui
il faut donc ouvrir des formations dans
ce sens pour que les autres puissent
être fournis sur l'autre question qu'est
ce qui dans la défiance actuelle
vis-à-vis des politiques est ce qui
ferait que le rassemblement national
pourrait apporter une réponse et faire
faire voter faire dépasser les jours des
régions alors j'avais préparé un petit
message et je pense que ce petit message
répondra à la question de monsieur
lemoine je dis qu'il faut à propos du
président macron garder à l'esprit son
arrogance son mépris sa détermination à
être le maître des horloges et à garder
le cap
on va dire que c'est une politique du
leur ne jamais oublier sa suppression de
l' isf et sa diminution des pensions de
retraite plus sur les riches moins pour
les peaux en fait il vous gardez à
l'esprit et je transmettrai ce je
transmets ce message aux réunionnais
pour qu'ils aillent voter le 26 mai nous
avons amir au téléphone qui est une
question également pour vous vous
écoutez meilleures possibilités
le réunionnais traitant de merci merci à
venir pour cette question qui rejoint ce
qu'on dit sur eux
sur plus de 3 alors plus plus
d'autonomie avec des spécificités bien
sûr il pour permettre le développement
de la réunion
il faut lui accorder
et si visiter et tout en étant attaché
est liée à la france plus précisément à
venir parler de loi régaliennes ça veut
dire avoir de l'indépendance sur sur
pourquoi pas notre mode et sur nos
relations diplomatiques avec nos voisins
sur notre vision de la défense ça vous
n'êtes pas forcément besoin de voir
régaliennes pour une relation
diplomatique avec nos voisins c'est
prévu dans le programme de marine le pen
de prévoit de une que l'outre-mer l
outre mer en général et la réunion par
rapport à notre situation géographique
que nous puissions avoir des relations
avec les pays voisins et des relations
nationales européennes et
internationales dans le mouvement de
gilet jaune il a essayé il a été
beaucoup question aussi de démocratie de
démocratie locale avec ses demandes
notamment d'un référendum d'initiative
citoyenne
le président il ya répondu partiellement
proposant un référendum d'initiative
citoyenne sur des questions locales
uniquement la région ici à créer un
conseil consultatif citoyen qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ces deux réponses
alors moi je pense que c'est le conseil
d'initiative partagée ce pourquoi il n'a
pas accepté le rique monsieur macron je
dis que c'est une réponse qui correspond
à un leurre là j'ai un communiqué
d'europe des nations et des libertés qui
dit qu' il ya il existe une initiative
citoyenne européenne
c'est un mécanisme de pétitions qui
permet à un million d'européens 1
résidant au sein de l'europe d'inviter
la commission de bruxelles a élaboré un
acte législatif
écoutez bien depuis 2012 sur 68
tentative d' initiative citoyenne
européenne quatre seulement ont atteint
le nombre requis de signatures et une
seule a débouché sur une décision
concrète
donc je pense que ça va être la même
chose les chiffres sont parlants donc
vous souriez pour le risque total même
si ça marche pas populaire mais même si
vous dites ça marche pas non suis assez
il est différent celui là le le
référendum d'initiative populaire comme
le souhaite
marine il est opération il est
opérationnel il est appliqué dans
d'autres pays il est opérationnel
par contre le rip que prévu coni ce
monsieur macron correspond aux is de
l'union européenne il
il est saoul il a une soumission à
l'union européenne c'est la raison pour
laquelle il a refusé le rique d'accord
localement le conseil consultatif
citoyen créé par je pense qu'il est
toujours bon de mettre un conseil
consultatif citoyen ça permet aux
citoyens de d'avoir eu connaissance de
ce qui se passe mais encore faut-il que
ça aboutisse après les dossiers ne soit
pas rangé dans un tiroir
vous avez dit tout à l'heure et il faut
réformer pouvoir supprimer l'autre trois
maires comment est-ce qu'on compense le
manque à gagner pour les collectivités
dont on sait qu'elles ont une qu'en
partie leur budget qui provient de
s'être trois maires il faut à l'impôt
supplémentaire
la faire disparaître l'octroi de mer
mais il faut introduire une modulation
de l'octroi de mer c'est à dire que
avoir cette taxe uniquement pour les
produits qui font concurrence à nos
produits locaux
d'accord j'ai déjà au sol c'est déjà un
peu le cas elle c'est déjà ça non c'est
pas du tout c'est quand je regarde sur
les marchés la quantité d'oignons de
carotte qui viennent de chine et
d'ailleurs qui d'ailleurs laisser
l'agriculture ne correspond pas à nos
normes on pourrait produire davantage
d'oignons de carottes et d'autres si on
avait eu peur ici avait été instauré un
autre admet reçurent sur ces produits et
que nos agriculteurs pouvait cultiver
son l'union par exemple c'est un peu
compliqué ce qui n a pas assez ici à la
réunion qui viendrait de l'esr très
beaucoup plus cher et ça privilégiant
privilégierez les les
les oignons les produits locaux sur le
passé mais il y en aura c'est il va y
avoir de la main de forêt cultivée ya
suffisamment de terres cultivables pour
les cultiver et moi je préférerais
beaucoup de réunionnais d'ailleurs
préféré consommer des produits locaux
qui par ailleurs a forcément plus cher
mais c'est ça les produits d'importation
seront plus chers mais ils seront pas
plus chers et sur les revenus donc sur
le sur le problème de des caisses des
collectivités locales comment est ce
qu'on fait parce que si globalement
l'idée c'est quand même plutôt de
réduire tous assez nombreux mais un dans
le programme c'est écrit noir sur blanc
a loué les revenus de l'octroi de mer
puisqu'il en y en aura suffisamment en
métropole les collectivités ne
bénéficient pas de revenus d'octroi de
mer et ça fonctionne très bien
à la réunion il y en aura quand même
duré pas loin oui mais elle a réuni à la
réunion il y en aura quand même et donc
à louer ses revenus d'octroi de mer au
soutien des politiques de l'état
stratège et des collectivités locales
mais actuellement si on supprime ou si
on réduit l'autre en mer ce sont les
collectivités locales et notamment eric
est ce qu'ils vont être en difficulté
mais le pouvoir d'achat des réunionnais
il va en augmentation avec ça vous
prévoyez pas de compensation par un
autre impôt par une autre association
en tout cas ça sortira pas du
porte-monnaie des réunionnais merci marc
et du swaziland avoir été l'invité de
lundi politique les élections
européennes on le rappelle ce sera le 26
mai prochain
merci et maintenant c'est la musique
avec tonio nous airgas 13 heures le club
de la presse sur la première on va
parler des élections européennes qui
faute d'accord sur rien sauf une chose
il faut pas croire qu'il y avait une
vraie tentative de conjonction entre
didier robert et qu'on soit pour ou
contre moi je vous dis je suis ni pour
ni contre le club de la presse tous les
mardis de 12h15 à 13h avec gueye le
dantec sur la première papa et maman dis
toujours que vouloir c'est pouvoir
ça tombe bien au salon dans la maison
les partenaires à gerpinnes d'edf exauce
tous les voeux papa et maman vous
pouvoir repart